hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round five of
the uh norway chess 2022 it's the
classical game between anish giri and
temura job of uh rajab of being one of
the candidates of the candidates
tournament that is um uh starting in i
believe 11 days the opening of the
candidates is on the 16th and then the
17th of june we will have the first
round of the candidates tournament uh
and uh it's very interesting uh here
rajab will employ the berlin defense
against anish and uh well it's a nice
test of whether or not to use such lines
maybe in the candidates tournament as
you'll see so anish has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 like we said we
will have the berlin defense so knight
f3 knight to c6 bishop to b5 the real
lopez is on the board and now knight to
f6 definitely not an easy opening to
beat and um
for a very long time there it was a very
difficult to even find ways of how to
play for a win against the berlin
defense
so here d3 uh we have bishop to c5 and
now pawn to c3 we have d6 and now uh
anisha sort of wastes the tempo as he
already played d3 he just advances the
pawn to d4 even though castles here is
the
uh
most played move so here d4 we have
captures captures and now you have to
give this bishop to b for check if you
just go to b6 d5 and white uh is just
all over the place so bishop to b6 uh
sorry not bishop to b6 bishop to be for
check bishop to d2 and here uh well
rajab could just for example castle he
decides to trade here uh we have bishop
captures knight beat the d2 capturing
and bishop to d7 now saying okay now a
d5 it's nothing and also if you capture
i can just capture back with the bishop
here on each castles uh tamer castles
and rook to e1 now you will have to
worry about e5 rook to e1 at some point
uh and rook to e8 there are some moves
that were played in this position like
knight the e7 a6 is in normal d5 isn't
known but knight to the e7 the immediate
97 uh by the job of uh sorry uh the rook
38 to baraja is a new move so already as
of move 11 we have a completely new game
so let's see how anisha deals with this
he plays h3 uh takes away the g4 square
from black's pieces also creates a
little bit of breeding room for the for
the white king and now knight the e7
offering a trade of bishops and of
course you do not want to trade this
your bishop is awesome black's bishop
isn't really doing all that much so you
just tuck the bishop back to f1 for
later use
and here we have c6 by the job and this
is where the game really uh becomes
incredibly interesting it's it's a
normal move you prepare expansion on the
queen side it's it's a move that
everyone plays pretty much in every
position
but now comes queen to b3 by anish and
now okay he's attacking the b7 pawn but
also he's putting pressure on the f7
pawn
so let's say you play b5 uh you just
want to continue you know a queen side
expansion knight g5
is more problematic than you would think
because how do you stop uh just
capturing on on f7 you have to move the
rook back and that's already pretty bad
it's classical game losing the tempo
like this it's uh i mean terrible
but even e5 is coming and for example
captures captures attacks the knight
knight goes here e6 we already break
through and it's uh it's a much better
position for white for example bishop
captures captures captures capture so
you're going to attack the rook here
we're going to play rook 8 to e1 already
we have nicely doubled rooks on the e
file and white will just always
always be better here so that's uh one
of the problems so uh rajabov instead of
playing something like this he goes
queen to b6 he offers a queen trade
queen to c7 is also possible
but he doesn't want to face the knights
the g5 idea so he plays queen to b6 and
anish says no queen trade queen to a3 he
just puts pressure on the ace uh on the
d6 spawn queen back to c7 and now we
have knight to c4 again putting pressure
on the pawn here and while you could
advance this pawn to d5 now the knight
d6 might be might be annoying and now if
you move the rook then even e5 and again
look at this position you you have a
defended knight on d6 that's not fun to
play so instead knights to c8 rajabo
just defends the d6 square one more time
and now pawn to e5 we have captures
captures knight to d5 and now rook a to
c1 nicely aligning the rook with the
queen and now uh how can black uh
continue this it's very hard to to move
your pieces this knight is really uh
needed here guarding the d6 square and
how do you get the rook into the game so
okay for the moment h6 creating a little
bit of breeding room for the king that's
always a useful move although maybe now
is not the time for it but it's really
hard to make a move for black and anish
goes for b4 that's a move pretty much
you can make in any position and it will
always be a good move and here of course
uh you do not want to allow this pawn to
come to c5 because if black at any point
it decides to expand on the queen side
the c6 pawn will be a weak backward
spawn and it's going to be very hard for
the job of the to defend it so here we
have queen back to d8 uh getting the
queen away from the from the c file and
now queen back to b2 uh we have rooked a
b8 and now pawn to a3 nicely defending
the pawn we have a6 and now rook c to d1
now aligning the rook with the queen
once again queen back to c7 and now
comes queen to d4 here also uh the
engine really likes activating the
bishop right away with bishop to d3 and
the bishop to b1 to grab hold of this
diagonal
uh but okay here our java place uh again
we place uh queen to d4 first and now uh
bishop to f5 uh of course countering
that bishop to d3 idea knights the h4
attacking the bishop bishop to h7 and
now anish goes for bishop to d3 just
challenging this bishop and if you look
at the position now uh it's uh very very
difficult to find a useful move for
black all of the squares are just
covered by white the the b6 square the
d6 squared the f6 squared the f5 square
also controlled by white so it's very
hard to find the move you could you can
trade here of course you can do this for
example captures captures uh but white's
position is just vastly superior the
rook is coming to g3 and by capturing on
d3 you haven't really improved your
position so capturing for the sake of
captures isn't um
really a good idea uh so here for the
lack of a better move rajava plays b5
and it is a sort of a top move
recommended by the engine but you know
that uh you okay you have to play this
the knight will now uh have to move from
an active square uh and you will
activate your pieces a little bit but
you will be stuck with the backwards c6
spawn and that's going to be a huge
problem so here anis just trades
captures with check captures and knight
to a5 already putting pressure on the c6
pawn and the knight seat the e7 now
adding more defenders to the pawn we
have rook to c1 now attacking the pawn
and now rook beat the d8 we have queen
e4 check king to h8 and now knight to f3
now this knight can come to d4 and it's
gonna put even more pressure on the c6
pawn and here the question is uh do you
push f5 or not now if you push f5 it's a
fine move white can even capture alpha
son on on f6
but
if white just moves the queen you've
given white a pass pawn basically for
free and the f5 pawn doesn't really do
all that much so rajab decides against
this he plays queen to d7
again getting the queen away from the
from the c file and now rook c2 anish
just prepares to double up on the c file
uh we have knight to g6 and here with
rook the c8 you still kind of continue
defending but it's an incredibly passive
position and the job is very long on
time so he goes for the active knight to
g6 but it doesn't help him all that much
now anish just grabs the pawn knight
captures on c6 rook the c8 putting
pressure on the knight and rook eat the
c1 so doubling up here
we have knight to g to f4 and now knight
c to d4 uh look at this uh sorry knight
seatta d for offering a trade of rooks
and here rook captures on c2 rook
captures and pawn to f6 now trying to
undermine white's position of course you
cannot capture the queen is now on e4
but you can play this beautiful rook the
c5 move and uh what what do you do now
uh well we have f captures on e5 knight
captures on e5 now threatening all sorts
of uh
nasty checks here if if of course our
jabba allows it
and there really isn't a good move here
for black here uh rajabov tries knight
to c3 but the position is lost
regardless of of what he plays uh it's
one last trick in the position that
might work but it's very unlikely that
it will but still you are extremely low
on time you have to play something so
rook captures in c3 and now arajabo goes
for the move from the thumbnail queen
cactus on d4 hoping for queen captures
and knight to e2 a beautiful royal fork
but even with this white's position
would still be
winning with with perfect play uh so
instead after queen captures on d4 anish
just played knight to f7 check and he
was in this position on move 40 that's
temura jabo resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you can't go to h7 so you are losing the
rook here with check for example king g8
we're going to capture this with check
king h7 and now rook c6 uh taking away
the square from the king and you are
getting checkmated now there is really
nothing you can play you can deliver one
check but that's it there's no defending
this um
this will just be checkmate uh so yeah
of course after knight to f7 checker
resigned and a wonderful victory for
anish
in this uh well a really weird line of
the berlin defense so where we did not
have a positive video moment in this
video uh which is weird as i know you
guys really enjoy those and i enjoy uh
preparing those uh but here there just
wasn't that moment of tension where you
know a move would decide the outcome of
the game it was just that um
basically from the start from the line
that rajab chose of the berlin
his position just kept deteriorating
move by move by move by move so
we could even say that maybe after let's
say this um a c6 move maybe even after
c6 the position is already an incredibly
difficult one to play if we would ask uh
some crazy version a version of
stockfish or alpha zero
probably they would say okay c6 white is
maybe
uh plus seven or but but who knows
uh so it was just a very very difficult
um position to to play positionally
against someone as strong as anish uh so
yeah uh there you have it uh
it's very hard to pinpoint the exact
moment where ahrajaw went wrong but you
know if you play a shaky line and for
someone as strong as anish this is
definitely shaky uh you will you will be
punished but also uh he did try it out
and uh you know if he had some ideas of
maybe using it in the candidates
tournament uh maybe now not so much or
maybe he's just gonna improve it we'll
see what happens uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it here are
the standings so we don't forget after
round five uh so anand is leading the
tournament with 10 points in seoul lead
uh if he won that game at the classical
game against magnus he would be uh
far far ahead of everyone but uh as
magnus was able to to get a draw on and
only uh is now uh half a point in the
lead magnus carlsen uh in second with
nine and a half with it and a half
wesley so and shakira mahmoud with seven
maximum shala graham and anishigiri
with four and a half wang khao with
three and temura java with three points
uh most likely uh saving all of his
preparation for the candidates
tournament but that is of course to be
expected as you know you're not gonna
waste it now the candidates tournament
starts in 11 days
but yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it a very nice positional
masterpiece i would like to thank
richard knapp uh raymond young cedra
simmons evalia and lego and the david
kimura for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament uh until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day